- Used to stutter a lot.
I couldn't speak to someone.
I couldn't look at them in the eyes.
Everything was just intimidating to me.
I used to be a totally different person
before I got into the program.
Look at me now.
I'm the group commander.
I'm number one.
I'm in charge.
To the rear.
March!
I really wanna be a lawyer
inside the military.
And I have to do a lot
of things to get there.
That's what I love about it
because it pushed me to study
just like ROTC pushed me.
I'm a very determined person.
I won't stop until I get what I want,
so practice, practice, practice
and practice for my SAT.
If I have to study more,
if I have to stay up,
I will do it to get there.
I know there's a reward at the end,
but I'm not working for the reward.
I'm working for something bigger.
I'm gonna keep going because
this is what I wanna do.
This is my goal, and
I wanna accomplish it.
(upbeat, driving music)